cinéma maintenant avec la sortie
aujourd'hui sur les écrans d'un dessin
animé bien français astérix et les
vikings une adaptation d' astérix et les
normands écrit par goscinny en 67
marylène bono vincent bouffartigue *
prends ta position avec les wheat kings
ça peut toujours servir
écoute qu'il trouvera bâtiment puma tout
droit jusqu'au premier exit les romains
pour cette fois le peuple de loi se bat
contre des brutes venus du nord et les
vikings complaisance bourse
il a pour les retrouve pas mâcher des
champions ils ont enlevé goudurix le
neveu du chef du village pitié c'est
quoi ça de nouveaux personnages
apparaissent look de nouvelles voies qui
écouter la parole donnée pierre palmade
et cryptographe s'il rêve d'être le chef
des liquides
lorànt deutsch goudurix le jeune
blondinet de lutèce astérix a depuis 40
ans lui la même voix celle de roger
carel qu'il n'avait travaillé avec
uderzo et goscinny
mais si cette voie un peu plus cirer un
peu plus aigu comme ça pour le
personnage elle leur convenaient
parfaitement il ya moi aussi
jamais entendu de musique aussi ringarde
le film est inspiré d'un album sorti en
1967 un peu modernisé quand même
mais ce sont toujours les enfants qui en
parlent le mieux toujours noir au mal
qui s'est toujours les gaulois 2,80 ghz
une potion magique pourquoi c'est
l'habitude de battre contre eux qui loge
hier romain cent mille dessins ont été
réalisés pour ce film qui a coûté 22
millions d'euros
déjà 40 pays ont acheté ce produit made
in gaulle
ces sms short message service et après
la bd au cinéma la bd en bd tout
simplement en voici maintenant notre
invité des cinq dernières minutes